بحضور اقليميا ودولي انطلقت المرحله
الاخيره من العمليه السياسيه في السودان
المتوقع منها التواصل الى اتفاق سياسي
شامل ينتهي بخروج المكون العسكري من
السلطه و تاسيس حكومه مدنيه نحن نؤكد
مجددا ان المؤسسه العسكريه ملتزمه التزام
كامل بخروجها وملتزمه ايضا بالعمل مع
شركائنا
السياسيين والمدنيين بوضع الاسس والقطر
التي تؤثر عمل المؤسسه العسكريه في
المجتمعات الديمقراطيه
تبحث خمسه قضايا رئيسيه تفككان نظام
الثلاثين من يونيو واصلاح المؤسسات
العسكريه والامنيه اضافه الى العداله
الجنائيه والانتقاليه وحل ازمه شرق
السودان وتقييم اتفاق جوبا للسلام في
السودان
وقالت القوه الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطاري
ان الاجتماعات بجان هذه القضايا ستشهد
مشاركه واسعه من المعليين والسياسيين
لمطالب ترتيب اولويات الانتقال الديمقراطي
ومهامه والسلطه المدنيه الكامله وناي
المؤسسه العسكريه عن السياسه ووضع معالجه
شامله لقضيه العداله والوصول للانتخابات
الحره ونزيهه وشفافه
قضايا جوهريه ستناقش في هذه المرحله من
العمليه السياسيه تهدف الى اعاده بناء
الثقه بين الاطراف الموقعه على الاتفاق
الاطاري لكن هذه العمليه تغيب عنها اطراف
سياسيه لا تزال تعارض الاتفاق غير ان
الكتله الديمقراطيه في قوى الحريه
والتغيير فعلمت رفضها لاتفاق الايطالي
سنطعت هذا الموقف وسنذهب الى كل القصاص
السودان او وسنسقط هذا الاتفاق اذا اصرط
الاطراف ان تمضي بهذه الثنائيه المخله
التي لا تخدم باي حال من التح- من الاحوال
تحقيق الوفاق الشامل ورغم ان الاتفاق
الايطاريه عده لبعض اختراق لجدار العمليه
السياسيه المعقده في السودان يشكل ضم
الرافدين له تحديا كبيرا للوساطه في تحقيق
اتفاق شامل ينهي الازمه في البلاد هيثم
الجزيره الخرطوم